okay for people who are joining this
fairly rare Sunday livestream we are
talking about computational chemistry
and things being prepared for these soon
to be finished next version of off
language okay let's go open the relevant
guide page so you said it's called
molecules
I just molecule I could change not the
best name right I'm new to to making the
please alright
is that it those are all the functions
we have I know so what's the list of
ones we have let's so that that must
mean my my recent documentation push to
CVS did not go through because I pressed
update instead of commit and okay right
now absolutely going to commit right now
okay so let's just let's just check that
things are working here so if I say
molecule how do I get like a if I say
random entity chemical by the way
somebody reported that's a stupid bug
that's still there that this thing is
cut off Sushma with us
who is who is it I heard who is let's
see who is here
lots of people listed I don't know who's
actually here um well okay okay so let
me know when you're ready for me to do
this update so each one of these if I
say for these molecule a molecule plot
3d right so you need to create molecules
from them so you would map Mollica so
that should not be necessary good okay
so right so which all function should so
module has a take certain items and walk
I remember we had this peak order logic
a discussion where we decided molecules
are different from chemicals are not
entities so you can obtain but obviously
right but I could see the argument that
molecule plot and molecule plot yeah
it's just a piece of essentially user
courtesy I think because otherwise all
that's gonna happen here is what do I do
I say molecule map molecule on two
percent one and hopefully I will get why
is it so slow okay I'll get that and now
I say molecule plot 3d and that also
didn't work which is also long so so how
would I I'm not entirely certain how we
would combine those if we would just
make a a row out of them or so if you
make a list it's just a list of all
function so okay so that's what I think
we should do I been
now that's that some reason why we think
that's a bad idea because of something
in the future with multiple molecules I
would be hesitant also here to make this
immediately cuz I mean it could you
could imagine that somebody would just
want to see the two them combined in a
grid of some kind I guess um or if you
do molecule plot 3d of a list of two
molecules you might want to have them
together in the same same frame
positioned how right that so it's not
entirely obvious how to do that yeah
they should be joined first into a
single frame before they would be shown
together and possibly overlapping
basically making a new molecule that has
two separate pieces of stuff in them
right um okay but but let's go back to
the question of whether molecule plot 3d
should just work on um
[Music]
comical entities yes and so so if the
chemical entity itself has Adam corner
the atom positions the 3d coordinates in
our knowledge base then which don't I
thought all of them did no there's a
there's a fair number that that don't
salts or just ones that um when we get
them from our source they didn't have it
and various metal complexes what is this
what would a salt do so like we're
talking sodium chloride or something
right so so in this point in this case
if those entities don't have 3d
coordinates molecule is going to try and
create them and molecule will do that it
will it'll embed the this disconnected
components and then just place them in
in the same way the graph will layout
disconnect two components okay does that
make sense I think so okay so this is
something where it says unable to
generate so when when it says generate
in 3d coordinates is it computing them
or are they pre computed here so in that
case it's computing them
why don't we store the pre computed once
at least for the word for the molecules
that we know are in the knowledge base
rate I have gone through and on a couple
of occasions and tried to update and
compute pre compute them for ones in the
in the knowledge base and there were
some that just did fail no so what the
heck happened here right so that's got
disk on half now Matt right and so the
hafnium is just that that that lone
sphere and so right so the the embedding
routine that I have right now will embed
the the different components separately
and then combine them just just laying
them out okay but in this particular
case so what does this mean here
in this case what does this mean there's
a random piece of hafnium there right so
in reality that the bonds in that
complex are probably let's see I would
imagine that you've got the two planes
that are parallel to each other and
hafnium is in there somewhere in between
and you have the ions hanging out around
the hafnium but the the bonding of that
metal complex was is a little bit more
complicated that then can be just
described using a single and double
bonds and so our sources didn't provide
us with any bonds from hafnium to the to
the the cyclic cyclic compounds there
and so we don't have any bonds going to
half neom okay but so hold on that there
multiple issues here okay so let's start
off with the most so I had not realised
I think we had talked about it before
that there are molecules that have this
kind of brokenness in them or even this
kind of brokenness where I can't do
anything what happened when it couldn't
do anything I mean what why isn't this
just a bunch of disconnected atoms in
the case where it can do practically
nothing well it is handling that okay up
to the connected components but it
doesn't know how to connect them
together based on charge interactions
and things like that that's because you
can only do certain kinds of well-known
atom types is that correct that's part
of it and the organic parts can
certainly put together like the one on
the right the magnesium bromide compound
it handled the organic part just fine
but the magnesium and the bromine should
be associated to each other not too far
away because of the ionic attraction
between the two and the benzene ring
should probably also be coordinated with
the magnesium or possibly the oxygen and
the ether would be armed
but the the rules for inorganic
chemistry are much different than those
who organic chemistry and the library
using does not have anything to handle
the inorganic
part so this doesn't exist as a part of
the state of the Autobots I'm not that
familiar with it myself there are some
force fields you as it were for in
organics I don't know how extensive they
are or how much they're used but I have
there's a chap who is that our
technology conference last year who is a
force field aficionado who wants it
wants it to get us to use some force
facility he worked for in the National
Labs maybe Danielle could check into
that yeah I don't remember who that was
I only met the the one chemist from
University of Virginia I think it was
okay so so there are a few of these some
so that's that there's also as this chap
at Harvard who we did a bunch of stuff
with a number of years ago um and it
might be worth I mean I think ultimately
what he had hoped to be able to do of
some kind of ab initio computation of
molecular structures didn't work out at
least at that time but it would be nice
to recontact these people and see if
this is now doable
he's not at a lot anymore he moved to
Canada okay well whatever but uh um but
even so even there with the stuff that
uh that he was doing it focuses on more
on connected molecules rather than metal
complexes and things that they you need
more you need more of the crystal
structure to in order to describe how
they're they're laid out right okay so
let slip okay so that so this is my
chemistry learning moment here but but
um let's just do sodium chloride here
let me just understand so you're saying
if you have disconnected for you fail
you get a message there at least no so
so I make the so we don't have a way of
doing an educated layout Oh what
happened here okay so so that would that
seems like that's definitely a bug I
will fix that okay but so if I say
molecule of atom sodium atom
chlorine right right what will that do
back is that doing it's got some random
weird hydrogen's hanging out there well
because you did we didn't put charges on
them yeah what do I do to put charges on
the string in in the sodium atom do
string formal charge goes to one why
can't I do any plus I wouldn't be
allowed that that would be more like
smiles it could be done that way as well
it it could be to I mean so I could I
could make it
I could make Adam any plus evaluate an a
formal charge goes to one yeah I think
that would be a good thing okay so there
okay so that's what it does for sodium
chloride and so then why does it say
formula CL and I why doesn't it to do
that the write their usual way round
that is correct they should be inorganic
parts are alphabetic so we do the hill
formula where you list all carbons all
hydrogen's than everything else in
alphabetical order just because we I
mean so we would need a heuristic for
saying which yes why not no I agree it
would be good to do I just haven't let's
find out the heuristic should be easy to
figure out just look at mean just look
at for all of our like for example when
we have if we have sodium chloride right
because this one is not yet abundant
object okay but so so when we have a
thing that says formula here right we
have we are using the conventions the
usual conventions about ordering right
know that NaCl is the the colloquial way
you would expect to see it that's what
motion so if you ever well know so in
this case actually I'm I could be doing
a better job because generally with
salts we put the cation first and then
the anti
so I could be doing okay okay so there's
two points here one is the to have a
string na+ here instead of having to
write the formal charge thing out
explicitly seems sensible doesn't it no
you're not sorry yes it does seem
sensible okay all right so let's let's
roll back here for a second to the
original question of whether molecule
plot should be able to take a chemical
entity and I think region of a pulley
heat on entity perfectly D of a pulley
heat on entity and many many more things
I'm not saying that the phone sink but
currently I think it's the right thing I
think that's the courteous thing to do
for users but okay this is probably not
the time to figure that out but I would
I would recommend doing this actually
sand on our livestream points out the
plots and plotting functions do not
generally show less stability and I
guess I'm caving on that particular
issue I agree that this can be that this
can require mapping out for the
molecules um okay so let's let's roll
back these issues so first point is
making a molecule plot automatically go
into chemical entities I think that
should work the second point is what to
do about these non you know non
correctly rendered chemical um chemical
forms and and I think there should be a
message generated okay so a message
saying this is disconnect to come and
this molecule has disconnected
components weird the relationship well
let me let me just understand what the
issue is if it comes form an entity
there we know it otherwise we might not
know like for the for the NaCl example
you currently don't know about the
bonding no right but if we don't know I
think we should shouldn't we say
something about how if you do a molecule
plot you're clearly not getting a
correct molecule plot I mean if I do a
molecule plot from this um
I'm just gonna get random two random
spheres I would assume I think that's
active because this example comes up I
looked into it
it's basically trust in the last year's
we get an idea how this looks like what
do you mean by that I mean it's a
crystal right I mean oh no it's a
molecule a in vacuum NaCl molecule is
trust understood the last few years it's
not a crystal it's a molecule oh well
does anybody care about that okay so
first point is there's a bug here
whatever the symbol Cobra zero arguments
is clearly wrong right I'm taking out of
that okay but but so you know Michael
you're talking about a free-floating
single NaCl molecule generally care
about that but this is what you had in
great detail discussed in your blog
about the ontology of chemistry that we
speak about single molecules yeah I
understand objects I understand that
point I'm just asking does anybody care
about the single molecule and I see yes
people are really interested how they
behave because they're really
interesting objects well but but that's
different thing from they being them
being the objects that one actually you
know looks at in sort of real-life
chemistry so in a case we clearly know
that something went wrong we're not
showing a bonded molecule here we're
showing something else right Freight and
so so actually the library that I use
for generating coordinates for embedding
the molecules will just won't even try
to do disconnected components if you
give it something with disconnected
components they all get embedded
separately and I don't understand that
there's there's a question okay there
are bonds and the bonds are made using
some kind of valence rules yes yes okay
so you know perfectly well when you fail
to make those bonds correct well so so
in this case there isn't there aren't
bonds to to fail to make there there is
no bond between my I understand I just
add it but with the half name thing
there is some kind of weird you know
chemicals
but you know you can't make it right
whereas you know in something like this
you know you've got a single connected
component made from organic you know
chemical components right right and
there are explicit bonds between do they
connect all the atoms in the other cases
here there are no explicit bonds because
it's electrostatic charge is holding
them near each other either in solution
or in a crystal structure but there are
no single double triple tight bonds no I
understand okay so I mean these are
ionic presumably that's some kind of
ionic bonding and quotes right now I'm
kind of and we would need to develop a
heuristic to make you know making a
guess an educated guess at what the
coordination chemistry is for the metal
and then coordinate the ligands around
it appropriately what you're saying is
there is okay so in a sense what we're
saying is these are you know covalently
bonded things right there are other
things which have ionic bonding which we
are not which aren't the subject of
useful molecule plots true statement
no they are a subjective useful molecule
plots we just don't have the capability
right now to give them good 3d
coordinates because we don't have stuff
that handles the coordination chemistry
right we don't embed separate components
together intelligently I lay them out so
that visually they don't overlap and I
actually would be fine with issuing a
message saying that yeah well I agree
that's what I think we should do because
yeah um I mean so in other words okay so
there's two branches to this issue one
is you know it would be nice to see if
we can find you know some ability to
actually compute these I mean are at a
very naive level is this not determined
by just electrostatics
by the reconfiguration of electrostatic
system yes and the electronic state of
the metal atom as well for the
coordination you know if it's got four
ligands it could be square planar or
could be tetrahedral depending on the
orbitals and other occupied but but so
is that already no one from a lot of its
known I'm no expert in organic chemistry
a lot of that is known I mean it's it
knowing given that there's a random
hafnium at so I'm hanging out here is it
it's not known what the electronic state
of that random hafnium atom is problem
no I'm pretty sure it would be known we
you know we how how would how would it
be determined knowing what the charges
are of all the components would tell us
what the charge is on the metal so that
it's neutral we're assuming that it's
overall neutral and then knowing the
charge state there's probably only one
or two electronic states that would be
allowed and probably a heuristic that
could choose between them right all
right so we should we should find
something like that to handle these yes
okay fine um okay so why don't we say
something like you tell me what this
should say something about ionic um um
tell me what this should say I you know
I don't know nothing about chemistry so
I mean something like um you know it's a
non covalently bonded components so so
the molecule contains multiple
covalently bonded components well it
might not it might contain none it might
be like NaCl um non covalent bonding
detected or something encountered
required involved this molecule involves
molecule in verb non covalent bonding
so I feel like we should just focus on
the fact that they're disconnected
structures and that would cover salts
charges or metal complexes I'm just that
well but disconnected with respect to
covalent bonding right right so that's
what we have to say cuz that's what the
connection means or we could just say
non covalently bound fragments detected
or something like that okay
bonded non covalently bonded fragments
encountered um probably bound instead of
bonded that just seems like a really
weird word non covalently bound um
fragments and fragrance yeah encountered
um displaying has disconnected
components
yeah that that seems reasonable okay but
it's not easy of this play it's easy of
representation
it's in the underlying object not in the
class okay right so the atom the canoe
the coordinates treated being treated
non-covalently bond
bound fragments encountered
and treated as disinfected components
being about being being treated
something like that is that right yeah I
think so yeah it seems it seems on it
seems right on yep okay all right so at
least that will give people some idea
that their actual molecule doesn't look
like this
um remove the word are here okay all
right fine let's go back to what we were
we have um comment if our live stream
just a minute typically yes look I I
agree Michael Hale on our live stream is
is reinforcing the in correctness of my
claim that we should have molecule plot
be automatically stable um yes
okay um
this case so I don't understand why this
isn't generating the same message that
this generated unable to generate 3d
coordinates
see I mean you're being able to generate
well maybe we should say encountered
non-covalently bonded fragments that are
being treated that that aren't being
treated Oh whatever are being treated
that's fine okay um but don't you think
it should in separately produce a
message saying the 3d structure is wrong
the rendered 3d structure is wrong so
isn't that the point of the co-parent
leaf right okay fine fine all right we
can leave it with that okay all right
let's go back to our guide page here
you
okay okay so let's look at where this
goes from the root guide page right and
so the layout of the guide page I know
nothing about and it should be changed I
just wanted to get all the song okay I
understand that I understand that so
let's go to the root guide page here um
so on the root guide page we want to go
down wherever it is Wow where the heck
is what did I miss it
oh here we go okay
well so we have a major new area why is
this bin what why do we not have this
crystallographic
Michael why is that not devil issues
visit sinking
you
okay what happens what's the
between what we've got here and the
chemical reaction data and whatever this
is that is a good question um I don't
know the whole reason I started on this
was so that I could improve chemical
reaction data so that we can talk more
intelligently about the the reaction so
chemical reaction data needs a lot of
updating okay but in the case of the
crystallography stuff we do have I mean
okay so this is kind of a mess here
because we've got multiple things going
on so we do have things like lattice
data
which I got which for some reason is not
mentioned here
right so
right now what's the relationship
between this I mean the whole question
of how the thing forms a crystal is a
whole different issue although I have to
say I would think that lattice data
should find its way onto that page about
materials and we should also really
understand why that what happened to
this what happened to this this looks
like it's got all kinds of grand stuff
in it
although I think in modern times this is
probably not the way we want to do it we
want to do it through entity property
and by the way that reminds me that
these pages need to be that's a all
these pages that have blah blah blah
data on them need to be read redone in
terms of documentation now that we have
entity pages
make sense
since we're trying to deed occupant
these kinds of function you know um so
do we don't have anybody from project
management here I suppose um so can we
um
I can okay
couldn't you communicate that I mean
that's a project for Brian and um how
long I think um gosh that's kind of a
complicated thing but in this page for
example okay so so this page um um so
we're going to need to add a whole lot
of stuff to this page basically um I
mean somehow this has got to have um
well there's going to be a section on
chemical computation here well it's
probably molecular structure and
chemical computation or is it primarily
molecular structure at this point
I'm not even sure what exactly can make
you competition would entail so to me
that means looking at reactions which is
where we want to go also should include
all the stuff we do with modify molecule
and energetics in terms of forcefield
optimization and hopefully one day
electronic structure optimization okay
but do you believe that molecular
structure is the right category here
ice I would say yes yeah yeah yeah
okay so then we've got molecule no
chemical structure because Michael's
coming bottles symbolic representation
of molecules and their structure is that
a fair way to say it
yeah okay so now what we've got under
this is I don't think we need to list it
here we've got Adam we've got bond right
right what else do we have here of that
type loser that's it I mean those are
the two types that it takes you know
everything else is handled through
options okay
well then we've got things like include
hydrogen's which I think a worth it's
just worth giving some indication that
there are things like that on this page
then definitely staring the Austrians
after bond rate it's it's more important
structurally than include hydrogen's
okay so now we've got um
you
so this is um well Wilmette so this we
gotta indicate that it automatically
computes by the way we need to add some
stuff up here why not um we got to
indicate that this automatically
computes atom positions
well render molecules with automatically
computed structure or something at a
first statement yes geometry structural
geometry the structure would apply to
both 2d and 3d but if geometry we
usually only we usually restrict it okay
so then we've got other kinds of things
here I mean this we're gonna have a real
page about this I'm just trying to fill
in this this approximate page
what's molecule okay so molecule value
how much stuff is supported a molecule
value what a few properties Elmont let's
see yeah we got doesn't say property
looks fairly ugly at the moment I've
been working with Bob to come up with
better names for a lot of those and we
have the major seven updated page okay
so should that be given before okay so
that molecule value well all fuel value
and then probably heap modify my what
you want well ok hold on a second um so
you'd say it's for retrieving computed
properties of the molecule earth
something like that values of computed
properties of molecules okay so now um
let's find molecule substructure right
so that's that's tells you it helps you
find a pattern inside a molecule and it
gives a mapping between the molecule and
the pattern okay so on this page I don't
think we're going to give all those
pieces
I mean um what else deserves to be uh I
think here
let's see you you have the where's the
modified piece here
what's that where's the thing is it is
missing from the guy page okay so what's
it called molecule modify it is yeah so
we're still calling it fine molecular
substructure right molecule substructure
molecule substructure it's very
to find graph isomorphism so let's say
molecule pattern and then let's say
molecule modify and then dot dot there
okay so now let's go to the main page
here um let's see what do we want to
call it molecular structure computation
or molecular structure look at their
structure and computation yeah okay
okay so that's some start off here
yeah again that this page is going to
need changes um um this by the way won't
won't render correctly that left hand
side needs to be tweaked ah ok this page
needs to be renamed um do you know how
to rename oh yeah it has a rien I can
assume I didn't know that rename make it
uh something that's very cool
no we did that for guide pages ok
remarkable so high-tech um ok all right
so let's go ahead here Pat needs to link
up to that uh and by the way this needs
to link to um
but um I like kill a structured
computation there we go okay meanwhile
we need to make sure that the graph
theory page is linked to this and so on
um that piece of knitting will need to
be done
you
I have to say that I'm not sure this
shouldn't be a top-level page
um from the route guide page because it
seems to me I I think it should be a
top-level page here I was like why is
social sciences um why is it that not I
mean see we should add a bunch of pages
now that we are able to link directly to
entity description pages um we should we
should do that okay so here what order
should this be in physics and chemistry
arguably mmm
do you think it should go right here
right that sounds I mean yeah so right
there with chemistry no no no after that
did you understand I mean so it's got to
go it's um I forget how to make one of
these we make them so really okay let's
go here
you
you
you
um sorry let's see what that's crazy is
that a bug in the Edit oh look at that
horrifying bug see that bug
you
you
I don't know whether that really belongs
in that position um you know what I'm
gonna put it in its own separate
subsection here I mean it's our first
example of something that is yeah um
okay let's go back over here alright so
uh is this how complete is this list you
it's missing molecule modify right I
think that is everything and there's one
on there that you've rejected in the
past and I wanted to ask one more time
about which is what register molecule
property no it's not gonna happen okay
I don't know what it is but but it's not
gonna happen not now right okay it's so
I have no last door okay so after the
last when it came up the last time in at
which a user had chatted saying they
specifically that is the kind of thing
they would want but it's it's an
internal function and if they find it
they can use it I don't even understand
what it's supposed to do you're trying
to so the property the molecule value
interface like asking create using
molecule value and sub values to to
retrieve computed information on a
molecule is is powerful and I am well
aware of that but this is not the way
that this idea of assigning values like
this you know how globally does it
assign the value did you understand what
I'm asking and I don't understand why
you're saying register it doesn't make
any difference you know if you're going
to okay what what is it supposed to be
doing it's supposed to be allowing you
to say molecule value of blah blah blah
equals is that correct Somali so you
could say
create your own property call it the
carbo I know but we yes okay
and so you registered that so we've got
a whole mechanism for doing this with
annotations for graphs and so on it's
not this mechanism okay okay so let's
not put this in y'all to go there okay
let's go back to the stuff that we can
do here and by the way we need to
understand how that annotation mechanism
can be applied to molecules
makes sense I mean it's there's the hole
this hole yeah yeah hey this is a
completely different mechanism than we
have for any other type of thing right
so so to me it's devalue yes to me it
seems like I like when you're making an
entity store your own entity store you
register a function as a property and
then whatever but you don't you don't
that's not how it works when you when
you make an entity store you create the
whole entity store and if there's a
computed property you give it as part of
the entity store you don't retrofit it
afterwards right right okay so this is a
different mechanism in the case of an
entity store
I don't is is there a way of doing that
as an l-value entity value equals I
don't think so Michael
so in minds assume trust cash I didn't
hear the question the question is in the
case of an entity store yeah can't use
entity value as an l-value can you for
individual ones but not for introducing
whole new ones right but it only when
you do that it is only local to that
session correct this depends if you save
out the entity store well fine if you
don't touch the entity obviously it
cannot be preserved anywhere yeah okay
okay but if you say but that entity
value equals will modify that that
entity store correct yeah exactly
fine but there isn't right now a
mechanism to add a new property you can
add new values to properties that you
have defined in the entity store sorry
said it again if you have to find a
certain property in the entity store
then you can add later on this over you
a new value for a certain yes yes you
cannot get a whole new property this way
right we are Jason wants to add a whole
new property not a value of a poverty
yeah all right so I absolutely not doing
it yet okay other fishes to fry first
okay so let's start off over here so do
you have a function page for molecule
yes
correct here right that's the wrong
formatting you know that okay I I mean
so I don't know how you made it yet but
I know so so please find out how to do
it so that because otherwise somebody
else has to come fix it
okay yeah
okay so you want me to retype this I
mean because this is what's kind
have to happen here so you do Adam I
mean this is the way you enter these
right you know that yes or no did you
know that disputed I yeah that is what I
was for some reason you didn't get the
thing to look right oh wow
something is wrong with the structure
you have here now okay
I'm gonna enter this one but then after
this please please do these yourself and
make sure it's right and who is supposed
to be checking this stuff
what what is the pipeline Michael what
are we doing here how is this being done
I thought Jason fights it and then both
look fou as the so but who knows how to
who knows the way that documentation is
supposed to work who in this pipeline
knows that
I thought eighty Jason by now would know
it so it's wrong here okay so please
please get this right
did you understand what's wrong here
Jason so so the font is wrong but worse
than the font being wrong it means the
tagging is all wrong inside okay so so I
will pay more attend
look at you need to get somebody like
Brian or somebody to help you go through
this very well okay fine
so he's the right person to do it then
with Adams Adam I am bonds bond I okay
no it doesn't create it represents a
molecule create anything no because
create means that it's a structure that
we're going to be able that it's a
persistent structure which it is not so
could it return in this case but it's
not any related it's non-trivial I
understand okay so the end is a molecule
based on gives the molecule
corresponding to the specified chemical
name or spiral string is that correct
yes
this frustrates me so much I don't know
wow I have no idea how you've incorrect
created that structure I imagined that I
typed it as a string and did which is
wrong right which is obviously wrong I'd
say you need to use the actual tools
which do the correct tagging right you
know how to do those yes
all this stuff with template input and
so on yes
so molecule is probably one of the ones
that I made first and have gotten more
practice since then so I will start it
anew right someone is commenting about
multiframe all / multi / pdb files
I assume multiframe means it has more
than one molecule in it is that true yes
this needs to have on this page for sure
we need to be talking about import and
we need to be talking about formats like
mol right right so out of the box we're
gonna support three formats for
importing a molecule mall to SDF and
mall and of those two of them have multi
frame support so you could say import
this SD file give me only the 10,000
through 12,000 molecules and it works
and it does it quickly as to what are
those things cool SDF yes is that what
we call it do we call it mole with
lowercase o L with all uppercase I
believe they're a hollow uppercase okay
um okay and we're interested in adding
PDB support but that's gonna take a
little bit of work I thought we had PDB
some PDB mechanism already or we can
import beautiful graphics for PDB but to
create a molecule from them they usually
don't have all of the bond information
that you need but it can be inferred but
it takes it'll take a little bit of work
I see okay but they really
beautiful graphics I know yeah um I
Jason I had some stuff to send you about
PDB and importing or they came out of
the summer school excellent
oops what did they just do here
so that would be um
something has gone wrong with that
as well um gives a molecule
corresponding to a chemical entity no I
did not
don't do that please right if it's a
name no you're totally right this was
the first one I wrote and I have an ID
okay fine
okay
unfinish that presents so what does it
mean i'm inferred from the from the
valence of the heavy atoms but what
about the include hydrogens thing
freight so that is an option listed down
below how does that affect this
statement Freight say include hydrogen's
is false so right now i have let's see
three settings for include hydrogen that
can be all explicit all implicit or none
okay so this statement here applies to
which of those cases all explicit
the default setting include hydrogen's
go so all explicit no no look III really
think you should go over these pages
even though they are not perfect we just
chosen I just talked about this now ago
okay
okay okay obviously you've got to make
those
right yes um Adam index so somebody
probably say what that is
only
only the atoms with indices ID sub I
listed included copy is probably the
incorrect world ready could you just say
gives a molecule or gives a version
gives a molecular because there's really
no relation between the two containing
containing only atoms with indices ID
sub i from all together with all
appropriate bonds something like that is
that right yes by the way could you
report the incredibly silly bug that I'm
getting a horizontal cursor here I know
if you can't see that through the hole
zoom session and so on can you see the
cursor yes I got it with a screenshot
there okay to the
oceans come along also chasing with us
let's see for what
yes there's hydrogen's attached to you
know id-1 id2 do they come along also so
that so you have different behaviors
there you can you can so if you said
include hydrogen's goes to none then
what you get back has all hairs where
they would have been okay so it's
handled by the option since we spoke
earlier this week last week okay so I
don't understand why some of this
documentation is in molecule rather than
an atom seems wrong to me right so okay
so what what all should go in molecule
like let's that says what is in the
molecule but but I mean knowing having
all these things you can set tons of
things for an atom got you so you can
only set those those intrinsic
properties and then and then everything
else is computed properties
okay but you're right that table could
definitely go to the Adam page the table
above it should stay on this page
because it's about
um
and don't say see because that's a
specific thing right we could say sy
with symbol sy eg see what's what's a
two letter one that we can actually deal
with an A or CL okay so I like this
because if I did have lowercase sim in
quotation marks and it looked wrong
because all atomic symbols need to start
with a with an uppercase so so I like
the sy there ya know so you've got this
thing linking see this incorrectly
tagged you've got this thing linking to
the page for constants I'm sorry yeah I
know it's just that this is what happens
if the thing so I I don't actually know
how to do this tagging so that that
becomes an italics string there's a way
to do that um which I do not now
remember there's some kind of special
input yeah you need to find out how to
do this okay okay so the the sy there
should be italic yes I mean I just did
it but I think I did not tag it
correctly okay pretty sure I didn't tag
that correctly and that will cause
trouble for the autocomplete er and
other things right because you don't
want it to autocomplete with that does
does Adam correctly autocomplete with
the elements of the periodic table I
mean with the things from periodic table
no but that's that's a good idea
it should do right and you've got to
give them a list by abundance probably
of the of the different elements
no not not natural abundance because
that'll put something like iron first I
think it should be carbon hydrogen new
things like that that are more typically
used for this sort of work
they have way higher abundance than ion
are we talking crustal abundance or
whole earth abundance well let's talk
crustal abundance
maybe there's there's abundance actually
we also have abundance data in humans
which maybe it's - which probably will
get you you know in so far it's going to
be oxygen hydrogen for water yes okay
and not carbon well okay so fine so
curate this left yeah yeah will do
autocomplete list only depends on first
letters so you only have to know see
versus see how and so on
yeah okay so I'm not succeeding in
making that thing italic so you need to
fix that separately okay yeah will do
what the heck is
this oh okay but that's not
the heck is this no look look this table
isn't right because this table no this
table is nonsense right this is this can
go in that position right wait I don't
know what we're saying here I just meant
it good
you can go I know that the table is
obviously wrong because this here right
if you're gonna do it this way
um okay look look see this something
like that right
I know what you want to call this I
says
you
right did you get what I'm saying
because each
those things could go in that first
argument good what I'm saying
any fsy entity whatever can go in that
first argument there so I don't so we
they can't do that but I didn't they can
also just put the entity directly in the
list and well aware that's what this is
saying here right but the way you had it
before this said that the only thing you
put in that first argument was something
of the form quotes sy which is not
correct you go what I'm saying
great okay um right right
understand yes saying what would you
call this first thing here well so what
goes in the first argument has to it
defines the at the element I know so do
you want to call it element there
so the problem with element is it has a
lot of different meanings yes right so
I'm suggesting it I'm asking whether
there's some different thing that could
have it be a little bit Kim LM too long
it's an e so obscure that's nasty but um
okay okay let's go back over here cuz
this this page is gonna clearly require
some work um we're really good if you
could do the obvious cleaning um oh this
is the wrong way round what you're
saying there is the wrong way round
right where the hydrogen's no that's not
what
Reuters was just right so that so it's
mine it's laid out better here
what do you mean by are explicitly
listed in the molecule that's not what
you actually mean
you mean that the molecule is assumed to
have them now that very explicitly
listed explicitly listed would be you
actually give a term of H and so on
that's exactly not what you mean you
know so let's see so when you create a
when you create something from a smile
string and H can be an implied or it can
be literally listed with the hard drive
well and so if it's if it's set to
automatic and you give it a smile string
with explicit H's in it I will turn them
into atom H in my in the atom course
right so now what but but if it not
explicitly listed you will add them but
you will not add them explicitly is that
true
will you add them explicitly so by
default if you do molecule of a smile
string si si si I will add them because
I think that where will you add them in
other words if I take let me go back
here okay so if I have molecule okay now
I say input form of that
oh I see the atoms are added and right I
get the impression that a lot of users
so people in the command for Maddox
community are gonna want them to be not
listed there to save memory and
everything but a vast majority of our
users will so just explain to me what
okay so let's look at if I do molecule
here and we say that include hydrogen's
so the default is include hydrogen's is
automatic so let's say include
hydrogen's is none so now let's say
input form of the Hat okay but now let's
say is this really the right way around
let's say molecule plot 3d sent 17 am I
going to see yes I'm gonna see
hydrogen's there right because they are
in the molecule that's just not
explicitly represented so what do you
think include really means in the sense
is it really the right include in the
first list include but could include but
in this case structurally includes
amenities this know that they're gonna
be hydrogen's added to decorate it so
after some processing after we've read
it in and we've looked at it and we say
no carbon needs to have four bonds to it
and here it only has two so we're going
to add two hydrogen's to make it a valid
molecule okay so this thing here does
not need to have an include hydrogen's
option to know to do that is that
correct right and in fact they include
hydrogen option is one that evaluates
away
so it's only on the input of the
molecule right
it is a constructor option I think it's
got the wrong name well maybe it doesn't
let me think about this for a second um
okay so then the possible okay so let's
look at include hydrogen's so it also
does double duty when it's added to some
other function where the name seems more
appropriate I'm sorry that doesn't make
any sense
so if you do bond list if a molecule say
include itunes goes to true or false it
tells you whether or not the thing that
is returned as I get it
what a mess okay so let's walk through
this again it's got two different things
that's doing you're saying yeah this is
nonsense I mean look if this says
include hydrogen's well since I think it
is
I find it leo all right what would you'd
like to write what this should say then
some option for the molecule may be
diverted a salt can be imposed another
secret I think when it's used in the
constructor sense it should probably be
something like generate hydrogen's and
when it's used in two different options
um um hey listen practical point we've
got at least four more hours of us to do
um I am supposed to do another design
review in about 15 minutes
um we are going to need to schedule this
this week is not exactly spectacular for
that ah but I hopefully there will not
be design changes um let
to try at least to get some version of
this page so so there's an option for
molecule that indicates would be um that
indicates what whether whether hydrogen
should be explicit or implicit yeah
should be whether hydrogen should be
explicitly included or not I like it
because it doesn't have this reference
to of a salt right are the hydrogen's
maybe maybe let's have atoms to do
before to avoid confusion versus
molecules okay with another functions
that specifies whether hydrogen atoms
should be explicitly included in results
or explicitly included I think included
because of this double usage as the
option because they are not into the
salt so to speak and I think you have
specified instead of specifies
okay but so let's let's look at the
basic things here so what is all all
automatic none or is that what what is
and presumably there's a true and false
as well that it supports right I take
true and all explicit and all to mean
the same thing
okay let's just get a small number of
actual options here okay okay so the
possible values are true
um there's not a table one down it's not
correct let's write it again add in
hydrogen's explicitly include or add in
hydrogen's explicitly
that correct for the class molecule but
not for some of the option uses well no
but it has to be for the option uses
because it is for the option uses its
when you return an atom list its include
or add in hydrogen's explicitly right
right presumably should refer to atom
list as well right right
okay so is that but but they import
least important is there's no hydrogen
so it's included in the computation at
that exactly but not in the result
that's my point
okay well then okay well that's what
this is doing so true means that and
false means um do not treat you know I
see
include hydrogen's implicitly
and do not generate in results well
actually we can simply say do not why
not just say exclude or delete or
exclude or remove
so I don't necessarily feel like we're
removing anything with that option yeah
I think it's I think this is the right
thing I think what we want to say with
include hydrogen's arrow false
hydrogen's are still included in
computations are still accounted for in
computations is that correct yes but are
not explicitly represented or returned
is that right yes I think all this other
stuff is irrelevant
what is
on the unpaired electron count so so a
person might type in a molecule atom
list oh and Adam list and to a certain a
certain user is going to expect that to
be just a naked oxygen atom versus water
and so so include the hydrogen's being
explicit or implicit they're both please
don't use this what's this doing here
why is that atomist
and why if you've said M equals why are
you saying first a percent rate that's
so what happened there so Adam list will
give you the list of atoms for a
molecule not the list of atoms in the
expression I think I disagree with so
you think that atom list should respect
should just return the first no no no
what I'm disagreeing visit the
educational point of this example is to
look at the structure that was generated
not to get an atom list of the molecule
because atom list does some computation
exactly you know so what do you search
first did the original one was what we
wanted to do we want to look
structurally but I think we ate it yeah
well except it does have hydrogen's
right because there are two that are
listed in the smile struggle so so in
fact we've got a different case here
we've got true/false and automatic write
rate in all the songs why they can't say
whether or not here okay um
include only hydrogen's that are
explicitly mentioned
that's right Jasna had discussed this
explicit and implicit whoa so as opposed
to true or false I don't think it's
right I think if you calling it include
hydrogen's it's either true false or
automatic that is um included or all
necessary hydrogen's explicitly any
hydrogen's explicitly is that right yeah
okay so we're gonna have to comment on
what it means to include necessary
hydrogen's right so I guess we can talk
about an atom's valence yeah I'm
completing there - okay um hydrogen's
are filled in so as to satisfy typical
valence conditions for atoms is there
right yes see there was a comment from
the livestream that I don't I don't know
how to give a response but we do have
partial charges as a computer property
for the atoms okay you just gave a
response that's right right I tried to
type it but then it told me I needed a
twitch account or something um
okay
okay I think we're gonna have to wrap it
for right now unfortunately um do we
know when we're continuing this so you
said this week is busy oh gosh you know
somebody's just having random things to
my calendar for today which I did not
approve that's not gonna work
well I did wanna before the let's see
this isn't included in master at the
moment can we can we add what molecule
the molecule so it's yes type only okay
yes yes we should add it but there's
still quite a bit of work to do on this
true
you
okay um look I don't know when this is
gonna get done so I'll send in a yeah
maybe maybe tomorrow evening as a
possibility um but as I said I think we
it's going to take another four hours
we'll be my guest
um I mean I wish it could be less than
that and the more you've cleaned it up
the shorter it will be I mean Jason did
not yet so much concentrate on the
documentation because we thought we have
some time to do this after Corey's so
right now we promise okay so listen we
gotta get rid of some of the junk like
this for example yep and you've got um
yeah I'm worried about design changes
here exactly this article it occurs
things design changes
all right well to be continued um and
for those who are interested we are
going to do another live stream about
geo computation in a few months um but I
will push back these results and I would
love to continue right now what we can't
cuz we got to do this other thing
um okay I'm a little concerned gosh
we've gone through most of these quite
extensively although I don't think
molecule modify for example is something
we've gone through in detail oh my gosh
I think the Afghans were but it's one of
the function is the most bears in
business if you spend additional
wandered worried yes I know I know we've
gone through some of us have you guys
gone through
yeah I mean right okay I got a wrap-up
here um I will see you guys some in due
course and for folks on the livestream I
encourage you to drop in on our geo
computation discussion which is starting
in just a few minutes right